bonjour à toutes celles r2 par le break
de faire l'actualité politique et
parlementaire de la semaine aux 45
minutes avec kathia gilder à mes côtés
mougeot à catllar toujours nickel et
dans l'acte us cette semaine le
positionnement de l'ump face au front
national qui suscite rom ou les
fractures après la législative partielle
dans le doubs le long débat la droite
appelle soit s'abstenir soit voter blanc
alain juppé nicolas sarkozy ne sont pas
sur la même longueur d'onde les
primaires de 2006 serait déjà dans
toutes les têtes et on parlera de la loi
macron l'examen se poursuit à
l'assemblée nationale sur fond de
polémique cette semaine le ministre de
l'économie a révélé qu'il avait reçu des
menaces de mort de la part d'officiers
des professions réglementées il a aussi
reconnu dans le même temps s'être trompé
sur certains aspects de son projet mais
le plus de l'hebdo autre soupçon et
révélations plongée au coeur de la
machination politico financière
clearstream vous en rappelez
certainement révélée par le journaliste
denis robert en 2001 la faire des
affaires comme on l'appelait fait
l'objet d'un film façon dans quelques
jours sur vos écrans et pour commenter
cette semaine chargée notre invité
rachida dati bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation êtes députée
européenne maire du 7e arrondissement de
paris vous avez été garde des sceaux
avant de réagir à l'actualité
c'est la tradition dans cette émission
je vous propose d'écouter ce que pensent
de vous certains députés de droite comme
de gauche d'ailleurs écouter les plus
conséquents des plus républicaine quinze
tombes de responsables sa propre famille
politique et donc de ce point de vue là
je lui rends grâce le contribué à donner
un peu d'oxygène et un peu le caractère
un peu salubre au débat qui a tendance à
déraper de temps en temps les femmes
dynamiques qui a pas sa langue dans la
poche et est dit les choses comme on a
envie de les dire
là elle a aidé nicolas sarkozy les
manière considérable tout à fait en 2007
au début de
son premier mandat et elle a fait un
travail qui est assez remarquable au
niveau de la justice
elle a refait la carte judiciaire est là
il a eu beaucoup de courage à l'époque
je trouve qu'elle a une qualité
considérable qu'elle a combattu vitter
la pugnacité ce qu'est toujours tout à
fait important parité il est un peu
dommage qu'au fond elle soit laissé à
l'écart actuellement par sa propre
famille politique au bénéfice d'autres
personnes qui n'ont pas nécessairement
le même talent moi je que je crois c'est
que c'était un gars des shows courageux
qui a entrepris une une courageuse
réforme de la carte judiciaire ce qui
était pas facile et c'est une femme de
conviction fidèle en amitié et fidèle
dans ses idées et un exemple de ce
qu'est le travail fait par l'école de la
république et y en a plein d'autres à ce
niveau là des gens partis vraiment du
bas de l'échelle sociale pour arriver
par leur travail tout en haut d'une
étoile filante que c'est un peu ternie
mais elle aime bien être présente dans
le débat politique puisque elle est
toujours sur les angulation et j'ai vu
dire qu'elle reprenait encore appeler le
service serait déçu certainement
d'ailleurs de ne pas avoir été retenu
par nicolas sarkozy dans son équipe
rapprochée
alors justement rachida dati qui avait
été au coeur du réacteur de toutes les
campagnes est ce que vous n'avez pas
quelques regrets
finalement d'autres laissés en dehors de
la reconstruction c'est à dire de gagner
c'est ce que d'abord ce que je trouve
ces droites et gauches les personnalités
vous avez interrogé
moi c'est ce que j'ai aimé ce que j'aime
dans la politique c'est effectivement de
pouvoir débattre sans 100 m dans des
affrontements stériles ou même d'une
violence inouïe
là ce que j'ai pu dire oui mais et j'ai
travaillé tout avec l'ensemble de ses
parlementaires
et c'est vrai qu'on a des points communs
ce qu'on est extrêmement républicain et
puis on qu'on défend parce que pascal
cherki ou ou même
monsieur nordine ben c'est vrai que ce
sont des personnalités qu'on est vraie
conviction ils sont des vrais
républicains moi je sais qu'on a eu des
débats vraiment extrêmement positif et
qui m'encourage en tous les cas dans
combat politique ensuite de dire un
petit peu à l'écart hall entendu dans le
oui mais alors pas du tout parce que je
les dis d'ailleurs une interview
évidemment je vois nicolas sarkozy très
régulièrement
il m'a proposé d'intégrer l'organigramme
d'ailleurs aimé proposer délégué général
aux questions de sécurité d'avoir même
l'imam ou demander même ce que je
souhaitais et même à quel niveau je
souhaitais mettre dans l'organigramme
j'ai refusé voilà donc je les dis j'ai
pas d'amertume ni aigreur
je trouve simplement que d'être dans
l'organigramme là à mon sens je trouvais
que ça et uniquement sur des questions
de sécurité
sam enfermés ou sa restreignait le débat
et moi je voulais quelque chose comme
qui peut plus large non non pas du tout
ça n'a rien à voir mais c'est marrant
vous c'est vous qui fermait le solde non
il m'a dit j'ai dit à nicolas sarkozy
que je le soutenais que j'étais
effectivement je défends dès que je
défende est effectivement ces combats et
je le soutiens dans non sans travail pas
facile de près dans l'ump
pour autant je ne souhaitais pas
m'enfermer dans dans une chez nous un
organigramme parce que je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui le débat que nous avons
en france et l'état de la france exige
que nous soyons effectivement moi je
considère un peu sur tous les fronts un
peu sur tous les sujets et d'être au
premier rang de tous les combats c'est
pas dit non c'est pas l'histoire de
liberté du tout puisque si c'était le
cas je le dirai ça n'est pas ça c'est de
pouvoir aborder tous les sujets d'être
de tous les tous les combats et tous les
débats sur toutes les questions
c'est vrai que si vous êtes sur les
questions de sécurité c'est plus
compliqué de d'aborder les questions
d'éducation les questions d'équité et de
justice
donc quoi mais ça a été d'ailleurs j'ai
revu encore la semaine dernière que la
sarkozie qui m'a redemandé non sais
c'est que points
je considère je suis à ma place à droite
je suis à ma place à l'ump mort avait su
de tout et les combats et jeu
ailleurs et je suis entre je vais en
france soutenir d'ailleurs nos candidats
aux élections départementales
donc je fais pleinement parti de ces
familles politiques
et contrairement aux derniers
intervenants je ne suis pas du tout que
l'on vous à 2 et non mais je trouve
d'ailleurs regardez vos l'actualité est
riche et les sujets fondamentaux sont
très raisonnée et notre famille
politique doit se positionner sur tous
ces sujets justement je vous propose de
parler de la loi macro et de tout le
pataquès cumul qui a eu dans l'hémicycle
le ministre lui joue la transparence
le coeur du texte c'est la réforme des
professions réglementées le ministre de
l'économie a fait son mea culpa il sait
il a reconnu s'être trompé sur la
question de la baisse des tarifs des
notaires et au même moment il révélait
aussi une existence de menaces de mort
vous propose d'y voir plus clair avec
elsa mondain gavât et maxence cani c'est
l'un des volets les plus explosifs de la
loi macron la réforme des professions
réglementées
une mesure attaqué de toutes parts et
surtout par les notaires eux mêmes qui
n'ont pas hésité à mener une campagne de
lobbying est annoncée 15000 destructions
d'emplois ils ont provoqué la colère des
manuels macro je n'accepte pas comme
argument des chiffres qui de manière
scandaleuse ont été mises en avant par
certains professionnels sans aucun
fondement sans aucune preuve et sans
aucun sérieux je ne fais honnêtement
même pas référence aux menaces de mort
j'ai porté plaintes que j'ai reçues de
certains officiers publics et
ministériels parce que vous m'accorderez
sur le fait que c'est particulièrement
étonnant le gouvernement revient
toutefois sur l'une des mesures
critiquées
le corridor tarifaire à la place il
instaure un système de remise sur les
tarifs et emmanuel macron va même
jusqu'à faire son mea culpa
alors j'en finirai par le corridor
tarifaire est là en plaidant coupable en
quelque sorte puisque c'est moi même qui
est introduit cette subtilité
pourquoi je vais être là très
transparent parce que avec la même
conviction que j'ai pour défendre ce en
quoi je crois j'ai la même lucidité
quand je me suis trompé
insuffisant pour l'opposition qui ne
croient pas aux effets de ces annonces
jusqu'ici on ne parlait de croissance et
d'activité
le maître mot aujourd'hui c'est
transparence alors cette transparence
vous l'avez fait finalement avec une
certaine sincérité puisque vous avez
reconnu votre erreur faute avouée à
moitié pardonnée
il ne vous reste plus qu'à balayer de ce
qui reste de scories dans les
professions réglementées et nous serons
d'accord et peut-être même que vous
aurez des gens de l'ump pour voter votre
loi ça pourrait être consensuel les
articles suivants s'attaque au volet sur
la liberté d'installation
l'un des autres points très contestée
par l'opposition qui y voient un risque
de désertification juridique alors sur
cette affaire d' excuses présentées dans
l'hémicycle emmanuel macron a donc fait
son mea culpa ce que pour vous c'est un
aveu de faiblesse ou au contraire un
acte de courage
moi je trouve que au delà des
divergences que nous avons politiquement
et compris avec emmanuel macron je
trouve que c'est quand même un homme
moi je trouve deux de grande qualité
avec une grande lucidité et moi je
trouve très courageux et je trouve que
quand on dit le courage en politique on
nous demande pas d'être courageux au
monde d'être responsable il est à la
fois courageux et responsable
et moi je trouve que cette loi dans
lequel effectivement il ya aussi des
faiblesses dans ceux des oui parce qu'il
ya beaucoup
il ya beaucoup de choses et des choses
parfois même très différentes mais quand
il dit je reconnais m'être trompé je
vous renvoie une mia très peu d'hommes
ou de femmes politiques qui reconnaît
s'être trompé même quand c'est le cas
donc voulu accorder cela parce qu'il
aurait très bien pu dire le texte
le texte est non il aurait pu dire aussi
voilà nous sommes arrivés à un autre
type de compromis le débat parlementaire
enrichi ce texte
il reconnaît s'être trompé donc faut lui
reconnaître cette intelligence là parce
que je sais quand même c'est comme de
l'intelligence est donc sûr je posais
cela c'est vrai que les menaces de mort
ça fait pas partie d'une démocratie ou
d'un état de droit
enfin le débat de la démocratie exige du
débat des discussions le pas les menaces
de mort n'était pas digne de notre il y
avait beaucoup de choses dans cette loi
est un petit peu moins maintenant
qu'est-ce que vous retenez au final
sachant que bruxelles avait donné une
somme satisfecit sur cette loi
aujourd'hui on risque encore se faire
taper sur les doigts
non mais j'en sais plus si je reprends
pas pour les professions réglementées de
dire qu'il est important de réformes et
des professions qui bénéficié de ne pas
dire de d'un statut particulier ou d'un
statut à part d'autres les notaires
vivent ici où les avocats qu'il faille
réformer évoluer adapter ces professions
à l'évolution de la société
tout le monde est d'accord y compris les
professions réglementées elle-même pour
avoir travaillé avec eux il ya peut-être
des spécificités qu'on nous devons
garder et que nous devons garder qui
sont très française et qui peut qui
d'ailleurs pour les notaires dont en
europe on s'en inspire
pourquoi ce que les notaires ce n'est
pas une se bat pas pour garder un
privilège
il faut s'intéresser à la nature même à
la de ces professions c'est une
profession qui protège notamment dans
certains cas les plus vulnérables et
plus modestes ceux qui n'ont pas
qui n'ont pas forcément facilement accès
au droit où est la justice
moi les notaires on oublie que d'abord
c'est une profession qui permet et un
vrai maillage territorial notamment dans
les territoires ruraux
le notaire c'est un interlocuteur
important c'est un auxiliaire de justice
et donc c'est important aussi notamment
pour les personnes âgées et personnes
dépendantes les personnes un peu en
difficulté
le notaire est important à se fâcher
avec les notaires non c'est pas ça chez
ça n'a rien à voir c'est de dire est ce
qu'on veut garder encore une profession
qui est un auxiliaire de justice qui
permet aussi de protéger qui est partout
présent sur le territoire national même
dans des endroits où plus personne ne
veut aller s'installer
justement comme on leur impose une
installation dont ils sont dans des
endroits reculés
il faut aussi le protège des personnes
qui souvent sont en difficulté ou
vulnérables donc je trouve que le
compromis qui a été trouvé satisfera pas
fait au mardi tous les regards se
tournent dans votre parti vers l'ump une
défaite le dimanche et voilà le parti au
bord de l'explosion c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est dixit nicolas sarkozy en cause
des différentes positions des dirigeants
vis-à-vis du duel entre le front
national et le parti socialiste
on voit cela avec gerland drian après
plus de deux heures de bureau politique
l'ump a choisi de ne pas choisir
dimanche prochain dans le doubs entre le
parti socialiste et le front national
avec 22 voix contre 19 la position
officielle de l'ump
c'est finalement l'abstention ou le vote
blanc on revient au ni ni qui avait été
adoptée dans le passé que nicolas
sarkozy avait lui-même d'ailleurs
suggéré il souhaitait aller un peu plus
loin pour tenir compte notamment des
positions d'alain juppé ou de nathalie
kosciusko morizet cette position de
synthèse
n'a pas recueilli la majorité des voix
ce soir une majorité des membres du
bureau politique ont préféré s'en tenir
au ni ni
c'est désormais la position l'ump nous
allons tous nous y tenir pourtant chacun
garde sa position près de l'autre moitié
du bureau politique aurait préféré une
évolution avec une opposition claire au
front national tout en laissant le libre
choix aux électeurs la position
personnelle d'alain juppé va plus loin
c'est un barrage clair au front national
ce que je dis et c'est là qu'il peut y
avoir une différence comment arriver au
résultat que nous voulons atteindre
c'est à dire éviter l'élection de sept
députés du front national il ya là une
divergence certains disent en
s'abstenant
et moi je dis il faut peut-être aller
dans ce cas de figure là jusqu'au vote
pour le candidat qui la combattent mais
la ligne officielle du parti est actée
pour la législative partielle dans le
groupe si les électeurs suivent la
consignes nationales ils ne choisiront
pas une situation intenable l'avenir
pour la numéro deux du parti y avait
vraiment des deux de type de position
quoi c'était quasiment moitié moitié
dans le bureau politique et je pense
qu'à l'avenir sur sur cette question
importante qui ait tranché pour
l'élection législative du doubs dimanche
mais qui pourra se reposer en d'autres
occasions mais il faudra il faudra un
jour consultez nos militants en tout cas
moi c'est ma cema c'est ce que je crois
le débat est loin d'être clos
il faudra définir la stratégie politique
de l'ump pour les élections
départementales
rachida dati c'est le ni ni qui a gagné
ce que c'était une position que vous
soutenez faut je peux vous dire c'est
pas la bonne question le sujet était
effectivement suite à cette législative
partielle qui nous a surpris un surnom
les résultats faut aussi le reconnaître
qu'ils ont été les gagnants de cette
législative partielle ont l'impression
que tout le monde se focalise en dix ans
le front national non c'est d'abord
l'abstention
moi je m'interroge aujourd'hui pourquoi
notre électorat ne se mobilisent plus
pourquoi les français se détournent
maintenant de la politique aussi bien
pour le parti socialiste que pour le
front national il n'y a pas non plus une
déferlante front national il ya une
déchirure abstentionnistes donc ça veut
dire que
nous on apporte pas non plus les bonnes
solutions on n'apporte pas les bonnes
réponses et que votre parti quand vous
dites quelque chose mais plus entendue
par vous propose non mais c'est pas sûr
la solution c'est de dire aujourd'hui
- mon interrogation et c'est ce que
j'essaye de faire parler des placements
que je fais parler soutien au candidat
que nous avons dans dans l'épreuve pour
les prochaines échéances c'est qu'est ce
que nous proposons aux français
aujourd'hui et en particulier nos
électeurs dans le programme dans notre
ligne politique dans notre identité donc
aujourd'hui les français et les
électeurs ne vont pas voter
ensuite quand tu es pour le peu qu'ils
votent ca votent front national
donc ça doit nous interpeller nous
interroger donc on ne peut pas dire non
non non on fait comme si
non mais on peut peut être faire comme
si de rien était de dire ça veut plus où
ça vote fn et donc il faut faire une
petite combinaisons politiciennes
à lyon nous au parti socialiste pour
faire barrage à un peu de gens qui
votent encore et qui vote fn et le front
républicain ça ne fonctionne pas non
mais le front républicain c'est de dire
à une partie des français qui vous quand
même qu'ils se déplacent pour aller
voter et qui votent front national
cirque où ça vaut de plus donc forme ou
faut dire aux gens qui ne votent pas
d'aller volter et ceux qui votent ils
votent front national d'eau qui se
déplacent pour aller exprimer
un choix politique il ya ces gens l'ordi
façon si vous vous déplacez pas on s'en
fiche que pour ceux qui se déplacent où
on va être totalement sourd à votre à
votre choix donc ça n'est pas possible
que la position de l'egypte et de
nathalie kosciusko morizet est
impossible a tonné me nommait tu sais
moi je sais pas c'est de dire non mais
si on à ces positions folle argumenté
c'est de dire alors aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on 10 pouces on sait c'est
grave ce qui se passe
vous venez plus voter pour nous vous ne
votez pas ici non plus quand vous
déplacez vous allez au fn donc on a
compris
voilà ce qu'on vous propose et donc on
est on vous propose en attendant que
nous fassions mieux de voter si ou ça
mais c'est parce que nous en ce moment
on leur dit on leur dit ce que vous
faites est pas bien
alors maintenant vous allez voter pour
le ps parce qu'on veut pas du front
national je la mauvaise méthode que ça
qu'on n'écoute pas assez que lui même
pas des coudes bien sûr
bien sûr le juge il est là le sujet
assure qu' on en train de traiter la
conséquence on traite pas du tout la
cause moi je voudrais savoir aujourd'hui
pourquoi notre électorat n'est pas allés
voter
pourquoi les français ne vont plus voter
et pourquoi le peu qu'ils se déplacent
vote pour le front national et moi elle
est là ma préoccupation parce qu'on peut
pas faire comme si ceux qui se sont
déplacés n'ont pas voté front national
et là ce que ce qui se passe qui s'est
passé au bureau politique c'est qu'on
n'était plus sûr pourquoi ça va être pas
ou pourquoi ça vote est faite c'est de
dire on ne veut pas du fn et donc ils
ont trouvé des échos ceux qui ont voté
fn
enfin génialement ça compte pas parce
que quoi qu'on fasse y est on ne vous
entendra jamais ça n'est pas responsable
et soucieux responsables aussi de dire
abstentions c'est pour ça que je vous
dit vous êtes en train de parler
politique doit-il comme ça qu'ils disent
c'est pas dû dire abstention c'est
qu'est ce qu'on propose à vos bourreaux
abstentions je termine juste sûr c'est
de dire abstention mais on dit pas avant
moi je sais ce que j'ai à dire
on est surpris excusez nous on vous a
pas entendu vous a pas compris
pour l'instant ne votez pas et nous
avons proposé ça mais pour l'instant on
n'a rien proposé du tout donc c'est
irresponsable de dire abstention à des
gens qui s'offre hui moi je connais bien
cette région parce que je suis n'est pas
loin c'est une région qui chauffe de 10
souffre du chômage de la pauvreté des
inégalités on va leur dire la trêve au
chaud à paris nos sur un studio ou dans
un bureau politique entre gens qui
effectivement on se connaît tous de dire
c'est pas bien ce qu'ils ont fait les
électeurs dans le dos et franchement
c'est pas bien et puis là on va leur
dire c'est tellement poids volent pas
bien ce qu'ont voté front national
vraiment vous c'est vraiment pas bien
puisqu'on pas voter vous c'est encore
pire
donc la prochaine fois comme on ne va
pas nous nous on veut pas du front
national où on veut pas du vieux parti
social surtout n'allez pas voter donc le
sujet il n'est pas de dire faut pas
voter ou faut voter parti socialiste le
sujet c'est de dire pourquoi on en est
arrivé là
pourquoi donc on sait vous voyez que
juste d'observer un moment donné il faut
proposer des choses à nos électeurs
rappeler qu'elle est notre colonne
vertébrale très laid notre identité et
qu'elles sont valeurs justes mais
ensuite on peut donner une consigne de
vote sion
justement pour les départementales
cesser demain la départementale est ce
que pour vous il faut consulter ce que
l'ump doit consulter les militants parce
que c'est ce que cette ligne est bien
sûr serre sur ses consignes de vote a
donné ce que si nous les militants sur
une consigne de vote
on consulte à limiter des militants sur
des sujets de société sur des sur nos
valeurs sur la ligne du parti
moi je veux qu'on consulte aux militants
sur un projet de fou pour une ambition
pour la france on consulte pas les
militants pour dire c'est oui ou c'est
non
c'est cette phase est pas le rôle de la
consultation à la consultation aller sur
le pour le fond elle n'est pas sûre sur
la conséquence d'un mauvais vote c'est
comme si on disait on a perdu mais en
fait on veut maintenant c'est on n'a pas
perdu de sa mère dans ce débat-là me
gêne ce qui me gêne ce qui moi me choque
profondément
ça veut dire moi des personnes soûles
est pourquoi nos électeurs ne se sont
pas mobilisés
ça ça m'intéresse beaucoup de questions
qui se posent en france on va parler de
l'actualité à mardi toujours avec cette
nouvelle attaque terroriste à nice
contre trois militaires en faction
devant un centre communautaire juif
l'agresseur moussa coulibaly a été
arrêté sur place bernard cazeneuve a
évoqué quelques mesures écouter
personnage qui a cherché à atteindre et
il faut le dire assassiner des
militaires aujourd'hui à nice tu est un
personnage qui avait donné des signes de
radicalisation détectée par le service
du renseignement territoriale du
ministère de l'intérieur qui avait saisi
la direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure ce qui avait permis
d'ailleurs de suivre un certain nombre
de ses déplacements est de constater
qu'ils s'étaient rendus en turquie de
pouvoir ainsi demander son retour en
france et de l'auditionner au sein des
services de la direction générale de la
sécurité intérieure
rachida dati bernard cazenave évoque un
terrorisme en libre accès est ce que
pour vous c'est le mot juste ce qu'il a
raison d'un 15 9 a tout à fait les mots
justes pourquoi libre accès c'est
qu'avant effectivement dans les groupes
terroristes ou de criminalité organisée
c'était très structurée des
organisations si on passe à l'action
directe les brigades rouges ou même le
terrain ce sont des groupes structurés
idéologisé traçable
aujourd'hui quelqu'un peut se
radicaliser sur internet les regarde une
vidéo le lendemain 10 prend une arme et
il peut commettre jamais été sur cette
thèse ce qu'ont développé cette thèse
notamment un ancien patron du
renseignement
d'ailleurs les actualités de montre
qu'il avait tort il n'y a pas à l'ère
d'internet il n'y a plus de l'obs
solitaire tout le monde est connecté ou
être connecté avec une vidéo du bout du
monde avec votre voisin
donc il n'y a pas de loup solitaire donc
c'est vrai que ce terrorisme est pour la
traçabilité pour la prévention pour
l'anticipation c'est très compliqué
c'est vraiment très compliqué donc c'est
pour ça que la formule est tout à fait
adapté alors on passe à mercredi et je
vous propose de parler un peu d'europe
avec elle la visite d'un ministre d'un
premier ministre grec à paris
il est venu chercher le soutien de la
france
alexis tsipras ce le nouveau premier
ministre grec s'est montrée aux côtés de
françois hollande il tente d'obtenir un
allègement du fardeau de la dette
grecque plus de 315 milliards d'euros
bras de fer en vue explications avec
louis sybille fini la campagne
électorale le ton n'est plus le même
alexis type race ne tempête plus contre
les technocrates européens
le maître mot pour alléger le fardeau de
la dette grecque c'est la négociation
le premier ministre grec se veut
réaliste la dette doit être viable doit
devenir viable c'est quelque chose dont
on discute
l'avenir européen et notre avenir commun
et nous devons sortir de cette crise qui
s'autoalimente françois hollande a
rappelé les engagements pris par l'état
grec mais reste ouvert à des solutions
saas et l'objectif trouver un accord
c'est à dire de définir un cadre
économique que financier contractuelles
entre l'europe et la grèce et c'est ce à
quoi la france a dit sa disponibilité
rome paris bruxelles c'est un marathon
diplomatique auquel se livrent alexis
tsipras ce depuis le début de la semaine
une opération séduction
je promets je porterai une cravate quand
nous aurons trouvé une solution commune
et viable pour l'europe
très peu d'annoncés pour l'instant tout
se joue en coulisses comme ici dans les
bureaux de la bce
objectif obtenir de l'argent des
liquidités une des pistes indexé le
remboursement de la dette à la
croissance du pays
celle ci s'envole au dessus des 300
milliards d'euros la grèce doit par
exemple 40 milliards d'euros à la france
alors la situation s'était aggravée avec
la décision de la banque centrale
européenne donne plus refinancer
certaines banques que draco conditions
aussi avantageuses que jusqu alors
est-ce que vous pensez que ça peut
déboucher sur une nouvelle crise grave
en zone euro par la nuit
c'est pareil sentiment je n'y crois pas
je pense pas une aggravation je pense
que le premier ministre y tiendra les
engagements européens
maintenant qu'il demande un peu d'air
c'est légitime faut quand même rappeler
que le déficit grec s'est beaucoup
réduit c'est vrai que ses prédécesseurs
ont fait le boulot la preuve c'est qu'il
aime la chair dont dans les urnes mais
ils ont fait le boulot faut quand même
il ya eu quelques autres mais c'est son
discours a évidemment mais c'est pas on
n'est pas pour connaître par des
mouvements podemos ans en espagne c'est
pas du tout les mêmes dirigeants ils
sont pas du tout sur la même ligne ils
n'ont pas la même expérience pas le même
parcours mais le premier ministre grec
de toute façon tiendrons les engagements
il demande un peu d'air il demande un
peu d'ajustements mais ne demande pas
des annulations ce que j'ai pu entendre
il n'a pas demandé l'annulation de la
dette vous ou de dire je ne rembourse
plus donc aujourd'hui de faire
rembourser ce qu'ils devraient
rembourser maintenant qu'il demande un
peu d'air je pense qu'on peut c'est vrai
que l'austérité tel qu'on l'a qualifié a
démontré ses limites
donc aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y aura
des ajustements qui seront trouver un
compromis qui sera trouvé mais il n'y
aura pas d'annulation de la dette c'est
irresponsable thierry compris pour les
graines et la grèce doit continuer
notamment ses réformes profondes
notamment sur sur la fiscalité que
d'inciter un peu plus les drake pour ne
pas dire tous les grecs appellent ils à
l'heure un plomb il y a aussi partagé
sur la fiscalité oui c'est le problème
ça a été le problème pendant longtemps
mais aussi les politiques ont une
responsabilité puisque ce qu'on
présentait les faucons tu vois la
commission européenne puis sur la
commission européenne barroso en premier
comment accepter que le mauvais
responsable oxydation elle n'a rien vu
alors que ça fait quand même si au
parlement à l'époque donc il ya quelques
années quand il ya eu les faux comptes
qui ont conduit à la dérive des comptes
publics grecs dire que les réseaux
politiques de l'époque n'ont pas été
n'ont pas été poursuivis n'est apte à
qui on l'aura
on leur a rien demandé a pas demandé
aucun compte et à la commission
européenne ce qui ont validé les comptes
présentés on leur a pas demandé de
comptes non plus et après ils sont
rendus compte que les comptes étaient
faux et on leur ait demandé aucun compte
puisque
ils sont rendus compte que les comptes
étaient faux pas de sanction poesy
prononcé alors que la commission pouvait
prononcer des sanctions à l'égard des
responsables politiques grecs de
l'époque ils n'ont pas fait donc la
commission européenne a été complice des
responsables politiques grecs de
l'époque
donc c'est facile de faire trinquer le
peuple après donc maintenant les
réformes sont mises en place
il faudra aller plus loin sur les
réformes grecques mais il y a hot
il est hors de passion il est hors de
question que la grect que la grèce ne
paye pas ses dettes
voilà faisant de gym gère assez qui nous
a toujours avec tard au chef du site
le scan de scat du figaro c'est la loupe
du scan à d'autres partenaires le scan
politique du figaro dimur va commencer
cette semaine qu'à marc parent et
nicolas sarkozy eh oui encore on l'a
appris hier dans marianne
c'était lundi alors que le candidat ump
charles demouge venait d'être battu dans
le doubs nicolas sarkozy était en
conférence à abou dhabi une conférence
rémunérés est ce que c'était vraiment le
bon moment
apparemment s'était fixé de longue date
donc voilà c'est dans le cadre de son
activité privée s'était fixé de longue
date
donc ça n'aurait pas changé le résultat
de la partielle puisque c'était le non
moins depuis que nicolas sarkozy arrivé
à la tête de l'ump il s'est rendu deux
fois en conférence rémunérer une seule
fois sur le terrain est-ce qu'il ya pas
un problème à ce niveau là de quelle
nature est ce qu est ce qu un chef un
chef de parti doit donner des
conférences rémunérés dans des pays du
golfe comme le font de nombreux restes
soient politiques élus à la différence
d'autres il n'a pas de mandat électif
donc beaucoup de deux parlementaires ou
d'élus ont des activités rémunérées
notamment des conférences
il faudrait demander à d'ailleurs au
niveau du parlement
de nombreux parlementaires donnent des
conférences et des conférences rémunérés
mais nicolas sarkozy n'a pas de mandat
électif il peut effectivement poursuivre
son activité privée on peut se demander
quand même parce que ça l'air de choquer
un petit peu est ce que dans le cadre de
2017 s'il souhaite être président ne
veut pas dire j'arrête ce genre de
conférence après c'est un choix très
personnel moi la question
ce qui m'interpelle qu'est ce qui choque
le lieu où il fait la conférence de m le
pays en a mais est ce que c'est le lieu
non mais les journalistes c'est toujours
pareil c'est subliminal alors posé la
question dite par le fait de dire c'est
choquant que ce soit vous d'avis il a
fait une conférence à washington est ce
que vous auriez eu la même réaction
alors c'est ça la question est-ce que
cela renvoie pourquoi vous poser cette
question parce que le fait que abou
dhabi
le pays vient pas d'arrêter de
participer à la coalition contre l'état
islamique est ce que c'était le bon
moment d'aller dans ce pays maintenant
est ce que c'est le pays avec lequel
nous avons une rupture diplôme n'avons
pas de rupture mais bon est-ce que c'est
un pays qui pose un problème avec la
france
est-ce que
le président hollande ne reçoit pas le
chef d'état d'abou dhabi je pose la
question qu'est ce qui vous pousse à que
vous maintenant pour verbaliser les
choses quand on dit les conférences
rémunérés sont choquantes est ce que
c'est le pays où est ce que c'est le
fasse qu'il fallait compléter de l'aide
peut-être alors faut demander à tous les
élus de ne plus faire de conférences
rémunéré pourrait peut-être
et puis la deuxième chose de dire il ya
des pays interdit peut-être aussi
d'abaisser à vos questions moi je
considère que tous les pays avec
lesquels nous avons des relations
diplomatiques et échangent alors oui
nous avons nous avons quand même une
base militaire extrêmement importante à
abou dhabi est-ce que ça or on doit la
fermer
la question des analyses est ce que nous
devons fermer la base militaire à abou
diaby moi je vous renvoie sur la
conférence qui était donné par nicolas
sarkozy est ce que finalement c'est pas
une erreur que de refaire des
conférences quand on est chef de parti
et qu'on a peut-être objectif d'être à
jour redevenir président de la
république la question elle est est ce
que quelqu'un qui est chef de parti doit
avoir une activité professionnelle par
ailleurs il est ses parents tiennent ils
travaillent ils alors comme on
continuera comme d'autres dans d'autres
partis mais qu'ils essaient de dire où
c'est pour tout le monde pareil ou pas
le sujet il est là sa gueule poids deux
mesures
voilà en ce moment on est dans le deux
poids deux mesures vous faut dire c'est
interdit et tout le monde s'y plient où
c'est autorisé tout le monde si lui ne
vas tout le monde peut le faire s'il le
souhaite mais où vos générations
collègues que la différence entre avec
d'autres c'est qu'il n'a pas de mandat
électif
donc ça lui laisse le droit j'ai mon
côté j'avais professionnels toujours
nicolas sarkozy ce qui n'est pas payé
comme celle d'une partie des hommes
c'est aussi le sujet non mais oui faut
moi ce qui me gêne c'est d'essayer de
rendre sulfureux un sujet qui ne l'est
pas alors ou sinon il faut pas laisser
un
un truc des kumm de soupçons c'est de
dire voilà faut poser une très bientôt
je veux dire nous ça nous gêne qu'ils
fassent des paies complaire dans tel
pays
et après vous dire pourquoi voilà mais
je ne saurais que je pense que s'il
avait fait une conférence à washington
sans vraiment à sauver autant de
l'innovation la part des journalistes au
moment des attentats
charlie vous avez signé une tribune dans
le guardian quotidien britannique vous
exerciez les politiques à ne pas
stigmatiser la communauté musulmane
au même moment nicolas sarkozy parlait
lui de garder claret à la civilisation
chaque cd propos que vous n'avez pas
vraiment apprécié le journaliste qui me
posait la question me disais est ce que
c'est une guerre de civilisation sort
d'une civilisation contre une autre j'ai
dit que ce n'est pas une guerre de
civilisation c'est l'époque de la lagune
guerre d'une civilisation contre une
autre parce que pour moi dèche où la
barbarie
ça n'est pas une civilisation quand on
voit qu'ils sont capables de mettre un
homme dans une cage et dû mettre le feu
et je rappelle que l'homme qui était
dans la cage était un musulman donc que
ces types là qui effectivement se
revendique où vous sous prétexte le
d'islam pour commettre leur barbarie
ce ne sont pas des musulmans il je vous
dis l'homme le pilote jordanien est un
musulman qui l'ont mis dans une cage
auquel ils ont mis le feu
je crois qu un pas pire comme poète
barbarie dont ça pour moi ça nous on ne
peut pas qualifier le terme la
civilisation qui a employé nicolas
sarkozy mais là vous sinon à 30 secondes
dit que ça n'ait pas l'air d'une
civilisation contenu d'une autre parce
que de mettre un homme dans une cage
ceux ci voulaient brûler ses palaces
ibiliz de la barbarie question contre
pour ce qu on vous a vu ce lundi réagir
à une annonce de nathalie kosciusko
morizet elle était sur bfm ce lundi et
alliali de cette petite anecdote pour
dénoncer la radicalisation la société on
l'écoutait le maire de mulhouse qui est
un ami jean rottner me dis que dans sa
ville il y a des dizaines d'enfants qui
le matin arrive tous les jours en retard
à l'école parce qu'ils sont à la prière
ces propos vous ont fait réagir dès
lundi vous avez accusé une gamme de
diviser les français démarrent en tout
de suite accusé
j'ai dit accuser j'accuse ça vous savez
vous avez évoqué vous avez évoqué la
division des français reprenait mais
pêchaient repris en commun les
internautes y venir ont vérifié vos
propos est-ce que j'ai me
10 j'accuse nathalie kosciusko morizet
non de diviser les produits vous avez
vous avez évoqué la division des
français en réaction aux propos jean
deneys oui c'est déjà plus atténuée
certes on peut certes certes à veut rien
dire
ça veut dire j'ai raison je n'ai pas
employé propos que vous avez tenus
henkel a fait amende honorable sur cette
question en expliquant qu'elle avait
finalement mal interprété mon honorable
a dit je me suis trompé
donc je présente mes excuses à ceux que
j'ai contactés pour vous gilbert plus
est grave nous sommes des responsables
politiques aient les dents quand même
dans un parti qui est un parti important
qui a vocation à gouverner de nouveau et
gouverner un grand pays comme la corrèze
qui est donc on fait très attention à ce
qu'on dit donc quand c'est faux et je
sais mon sac l'avant quand on prononce
des propos qui ne sont pas vraies là les
propos les conséquences des propos
peuvent diviser les français ça peut
attiser des aides de manière gratuite
donc en ce moment nous n'avons pas
besoin de ça c'est pour ça que moi
j'avais demandé
j'avais dit nathalie kosciusko morizet
parce qu'on interrogeait le jour mais
j'avais dit il faut qu'elle s'explique
sur ses propos parce que parce que ça
n'était pas merci et on va passer au
jeudi avec le président de la république
qui parle 5ème conférence de presse
beaucoup de questions et un long
discours
unité réconciliation ce sont un peu les
maîtres mots de l'intervention du
président de la république pour sa
conférence de presse semestrielle le
chef de l'état a défendu l'esprit du 11
janvier et fait quelques annonces résumé
avec samia déchire
rompu à l'exercice c'est la première
fois que le président démarre par les
questions internationales et d'emblée le
ton est donné
celui d'un message ferme déterminé
presque autoritaire ya un message que je
veux adresser à la communauté
internationale et aux plus grands pays
faites votre travail ligne de fermeté
qu'il maintient sur la politique
intérieure
est ce que vous serez un président de
gauche jusqu'à la fin mais je suis
depuis le début françois hollande a su
son pacte de responsabilité et veut
donner l'image d'un homme d'action
je les prends les risques le pouvoir les
prends sur la scène intérieure sur la
scène internationale le rôle d'un chef
d'entreprise je sais que c'est partager
cette trempe des risques c'est
maintenant que vient le moment des
risques qu'il reprend à son compte sur
le chômage toujours aussi élevé le
président mais son mandat dans la
balance un président de la république
n'arrivent pas à atteindre l'objectif
qu'il s'est fixé pour être élu et bien
il ne peut pas être de nouveau candidat
à la responsabilité suprême du pays
françois hollande sait pourtant que le
pari sera bien difficile à tenir en deux
ans et demi
le président a repris dans son discours
a évoqué un point important il a dit que
la laïcité n'était pas négociable est ce
que vous le croyez capable d'appliquer
cet axiome est ce qu un président de
gauche peut se montrer inflexible
totalement sur cette question de la
laïcité mais elle est négociable pour
personne elle est dans notre
constitution c'est un principe fondateur
de notre république
c'est ce qui nous permet toutes et à
tous de vivre les menacer elle est
menacée elle est menacée quand ceux qui
sont gardiens de ces principes sont
faibles voilà c'est drôle c'est débat en
disant attention attention c'est que à
un moment donné on a été faibles on a
été
peut-être un peu cynique et ont arrêté
leur politique compris géré comme tout
le monde
tout le monde a eu sa petite lâcheté à
un moment donné peut-être pour pour être
élu pour être élu tout court peut-être
pour pour faire plaisir et maintenant
voilà la république c'est pas négociable
parce que c'est notre notre axe
fondateur c'est notre sol qui domine on
met le sujet non mais y'a rien à
modifier notre notre république et qui
est un qui fait notre pays est fondé sur
c'est république qui fondée sur notre
constitution qui est vraiment on est
quand même en expliquant l'exemple dans
beaucoup de pays du monde
rien n'est négociable dans nos valeurs
et nos principes à la loi de 1905 dont
on fait une loi très équilibrée qui
permet à toutes et à tous de pouvoir
avoir une religion d'une pas en avoir
deux pratiques sont vu son culte ou de
ne pas souhaiter une fois paysage donc
il faut il faut pas toucher à ses
principes et ses valeurs
maintenant c'est de dire c'est pas
négociable effectivement c'est pas
négociable c'est à nous de bien être
solide et ferme sur nos principes et nos
valeurs nous avons parfois un peu faible
un mot sur françois hollande il a
endossé le costume du président élu a
aujourd'hui tout a changé
mais il est président la république le
reconnaître que dans suite aux attentats
du 11 janvier ils france et 100 g
derrière lui comme chef de la nation
c'est là où ça démontre que le peuple
français très attachés à nos principes
et nos valeurs et à nos institutions
et c'est vrai que la conférence de
presse hier c'est comment vous dire
c'est un peu compliqué parce qu'on est
encore c'est vrai dans cet esprit du 11
janvier qui doit pas non plus nous nous
endormir ça veut pas dire que tout est
beau l'esprit janvier c'est
effectivement d'être responsable d'être
dans une unité dans l'intérêt du pays
c'est ça qui est elle qui est
intéressant voilà donc hier il a tenu
cette conférence de de presse
dans cet esprit futur ondulant janvier
en sa qualité prevenar et mois passés au
plus de l'hebdo j'imagine que vous vous
rappelez bien sûr de l' affaire
clearstream
c'est devenu un film
l' affaire avait été révélée en 2001 par
le journaliste denis robert des
révélations sur les fameux listings
controversé sur fond de guerre politique
c'est devenu un film ça s'appelle l'
enquête avec gilles lellouche sur la
semaine prochaine sur les écrans simon
barbarie l'a vu en avant-première
entendu parler de clearstream
on l'avait presque oublié cette affaire
clearstream celle révélée par le
journaliste denis robert en 2001 dans
son livre révélation l'enquète son
adaptation sur grand écran réalisé par
vincent garenq nous replonge dans cette
affaire symptomatique de l'argent roi ou
la dissimulation de capitaux le
blanchiment d'argent la corruption sont
facilitées et encouragé par un système
de coopérative bancaire basé au
luxembourg est appelé class trim
le scandale financier trouvera son
apothéose lorsque deux hommes politiques
français de premier plan y verront leurs
noms associés
ce qui m'intéressait moi c'est ce
personnage de denis robert et son
enquête parce que j'avais l'impression
qu'avec sarkozy de villepin ce qu'on
nous avait raconté en avait plus de sens
et que le grand public là n'est vraiment
pas du tout compris cette histoire
l'enquète c'est aussi l'histoire d'un
homme
le journaliste denis robert incarné par
gilles lellouche ces révélations ne
furent pas sans conséquence pour sa vie
privée soixante trois procédures et 400
visites d'huissiers furent le prix à
payer de sa liberté d'expression
c'était un lanceur dans l'air qui l'air
de rien il a et c'est cette thématique
des lanceurs der sar vient beaucoup on a
besoin de gens comme ça mais ces gens là
où encore aujourd'hui se prennent des
procès lorsqu'il a sorti le son premier
livre révélation toute la campagne promo
a été annulé
l'espace de 48 heures donc évidemment
tous ses collègues journalistes
remettait en cause la véracité de ses
dires de son enquête même le bien fondé
de ce pourquoi il faisait tous ça
vincent garenq et gilles lellouche
réussissent la prouesse de fer de classe
trim un thriller grand public et
passionnant une prouesse pour l'un des
scandales les plus complexes de la vème
république
rachida dati vous avez été ministre de
la justice assem garde des sceaux qu'est
ce qu'il reste de toute cette affaire
clearstream c'est laurent voir un film
mais aussi le combat de cet homme denis
robert parce que c'est vrai qu'ils
étaient abîmées dans ces années
médication investigations d'ailleurs le
nom de lanceurs d alerte qu'elle était
utilisée je trouve que je le connais pas
mais moi j'ai toujours ce que j'ai été
magistrat financier donc c'est un des
premiers qui commencent à évoquer les
aspects au delà du blanchiment moi je
suis occupé effectivement deux aspects
de blanchiment dans ma cave
professionnel mais il allait au delà
parce que là il touchait à quelque chose
qui était pas encore dans la sphère même
public est élevé qui étaient les paradis
fiscaux
dire que île paradis à nos portes à nos
portes
et puis surtout ce qu'il a ce qu'il a
démontré c'est un mécanisme
c'est le mécanisme parce que certains
disent jean angers j'ai mis dans ceux du
gmi je vais raconte dans ce pays là mais
c'était là on est au delà de
l'optimisation fiscale
c'est de la délinquance et de la
criminalité ordinaire mais c'est de la
criminalité organisée faut foncer mois
alors oui mais c'est vrai que son livre
était aussi intéressant et il a été
sujet de beaucoup beaucoup de
controverses la fin du courage ils
m'arrêtent et me travaillait et le
continuer encore merci beaucoup on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine j'aime
mieux mais meurtre est bâti de
programmes sur lcp public sénat